if you had 24 hours with me and I
couldn't say no what would we do wait
wait I want to answer the question if I
had 2 um I would have her read some
scripts for me yes that is what I would
have her do put her to work I'd put her
in the back and say here are some
scripts that I need you to read for some
essay videos we're working on chica you
know what would you have her do what
work like what what would we do we need
help I don't know looks like a
prostitute my my like yeah you have to
give her a job that it's her skill set
what are you saying I'm saying when you
employee people you usually have to give
them jobs that fit their skill set well
she's a pretty she's talking she's lip
syncing there I'm saying we can never do
script oh okay okay well that could work